permanent representatives of Brazil and
Switzerland
ambassador
Ronaldo Costa and Ambassador Pascal
berries Wilde who will have a
declaration and I will take a few
questions afterwards thank you
thank you very much
dear colleagues from the press the
earthquake which struck Southern turkey
directly affecting Northern Syria on
Monday 6 February
is a heartbreaking tragedy amid serious
humanitarian crisis
we convey the deepest sympathy and
solidarity of our governments to all
those affected by the earthquake and to
their families
our sincere respect is also due to all
those who despite the loss of colleagues
or family members continue to work
tirelessly and under the most difficult
circumstances to help those affected
for years the humanitarian situation in
Syria has continued to deteriorate the
suffering Coast by the protracted
conflict has been exacerbated by food
insecurity the covid-19 pandemic a
critical economic situation A Water
Crisis a cholera outbreak harsh winter
energy shortages to name just a few
as we respond to this emergency it is
crucial to remember to also address the
previously existing needs and to
continue to respond to them as well
and now on top of an already very dire
situation the earthquake claimed
thousands more lives left more people
without proper shelter exposed to
extreme weather including snowfall
as rescue efforts continue the number of
people killed and injured keeps Rising
as well as the needs on the ground which
were already high
we urge all parties to facilitate access
for Relief efforts and allow for the
assistance to reach all those in need
rapid unimpeded and sustainable access
must be granted throughout Syria
all response modalities to which people
in need cross-line cross-border are
needed
good morning thank you as coupon holders
of the Syria humanitarian file
the needs of the Syrian people are at
the Forefront of our minds
we have been in touch with all
stakeholders since the beginning of the
week
reaffirming the unanimous adoption of
resolution 2672
all modalities of Aid delivery are
necessary to save lives and assist
civilians across Syria
as we heard also from the Secretary
General yesterday
humanitarian needs must be put above
politics
we welcome the rehabilitation of the
access to the Bob alhawa border crossing
as well as yesterday's first un-8 Convoy
reaching Northwest Syria with relief
assistance
this offers a much needed glimmer of
hope
and we appreciate the decision of the
Secretary General to ask under Secretary
General for humanitarian Affairs and
emergency relief Martin Griffiths to
travel to areas affected by the
earthquake this weekend
we believe that USG Griffiths assessment
will shed light over the effects of the
disaster to the U.N humanitarian
operations including those mandated by
resolution 2672.
in this regard Switzerland and Brazil as
co-pin holders have called for a meeting
at the earliest time feasible that
should serve as an opportunity to hear
directly from Mr Griffiths on his visit
to the region I thank you
is the security Council working on a
resolution to open a one more or two
more uh cross borders
as we just said as pen holders we have
called for a council meeting on the
humanitarian situation in Syria
specifically we want to hear from USG
Griffith at the earliest time feasible
beginning of next week on his visit to
the region as copenholders we stand
ready to facilitate agreement on further
action by the council if required we
will be guided only by the imperative of
addressing the humanitarian needs of the
affected population
Kristen
why wait till he gets back white helmets
have been calling for more Aid they said
they haven't seen any Aid in
Northwestern Syria yet how would you
respond to them
meet now the Secretary General has
already said that the needs are great
and the aid needs to get through as soon
as possible
the decision on what has to be done to
assist the humanitarian effort depends
on a credible information
and for that the visit of USG Griffiths
is key he will be conducting an
evaluation as to what the effective
situation is where the bottlenecks for
the delivery of Aid exist and in how
best members of the council can address
that so unfortunately we have to work on
the basis of information
pretty much thank you can I just add a
glimpse of hope our rescue teams have
been on the ground nationally since
Monday and they manage today still to
rescue a six-month-old baby with her
mother so just to leave you with maybe
that glimpse of her emergency Ambassador
the Security Council is not
demonstrating sufficient urgency given
the needs on the ground the Secretary
General yesterday said that it is
important for the security Council to
demonstrate unity and that he would be
very happy if you authorize the opening
of new a border crossings into Northwest
Syria the Security Council is not
demonstrating the urgency required given
the circumstances on the ground
particularly in Northwest Syria surely
no just I mean it's very easy to knock
the security Council
um as I said as we said in our statement
relief has started to flow again through
babalhawa
additional needs
an additional mechanisms that the
security Council
should discuss will depend on an
evaluation of the concrete situation on
the ground it cannot be a gut reaction
to to what is on the Press we have to
know very clearly what the situation is
and what the correct responses are going
to be and for that uh USG Griffith's
visit and information will be key thank
you
I'm sorry what steps are you
everything that can be done is being
done and and as we said all modalities
of delivery are important cross-border
cross-line and early recovery all
efforts that can be made will be made to
assist the Syrian population
in this in this time of difficulty thank
you ambassador of the opening of a new
cross-boarding would require resolution
from the security Council are you
circulating any draft thank you